foreign
the front lines are a little more muddy
wet and cold in Eastern Europe and as
temperatures drop the calls for weapons
weapons weapons has slightly changed I
have three different war three three
other words which are faster faster and
faster we appreciate what has been done
but the war goes on on top of military
aid Western nations are also looking to
offer financial support and supplies to
Ukraine's power grid Russia has targeted
electrical infrastructure and on Tuesday
afternoon Air Raid Sirens were heard in
Kiev with Ukrainian intelligence agents
citing attacks could hit the capital
this week meanwhile there are more gains
on the Eastern Front the Ukrainian flag
is now flying over Kirsten and will
continue to support Ukraine until it
flies in every city of the country while
Harrison is back under Ukrainian control
investigators are looking into claims of
torture rooms that were set up by
Russian soldiers Russia calls this a
smear campaign by the West Canada has
joined the G7 pledge to look into
alleged Russian war crimes
Ukraine's first lady brought up this
concern to British lawmakers during a
trip to London your Island survived the
Air Raids which were identical to those
that Russia uses now to put us on our
knees Ukrainian investigators are also
looking through what's being called the
missile graveyard in herkiv for evidence
of war crimes the local prosecutor's
office says Russia used weapons to
attack civilian infrastructure in
Ukraine's second largest city for months
Kyle Benning Global News